He was billed as the eighth wonder of
the welds are legitimate as a giant of a
man,
seven foot four inches tall,
then more than 500 pounds.
Andre the giant was the
greatest attraction the wells
of professional wrestling
has ever seen yet his appeal.
It went far beyond the ring.
With this humble manner
in his boundless trauma,
Andrea became one of the most famous and
recognizable athletes on the planet and
a genuine cultural phenomenon.
Yes,
behind the celebrity.
Andrea was a man trapped inside a wells
he never created and one that would
ultimately destroy him.
The man we know is Andre the giant entered
the world as Andre or one of them off
on May,
the 19th of 1946.
His father had migrated from
Belgium to France in 1934,
settling in more just outside of Paris.
In 1938,
Boris had married Marianne Petite
Polish women who seemed began producing
offspring.
Andre became the middle of five children.
Flores was a strong stout man who
stood just over six feet tall.
He works at the end as a farmer
and seen put his children to work,
cutting firewood,
tending the stock,
and otherwise getting their hands
dirty as Andre was 11 pounds,
but there were no signs of abnormal
growth during his first six years known as
Dt as a result of a system
is pronouncing his name.
He was a healthy good
looking and charming child's,
but as he grew older,
his rate of fiscal growth
outstrips that of his peers.
This was especially noticeable in his
face were his drawer and foreheads became
unusually pronounced.
Andrea,
it again is ending school nearby.
It will see some mall.
He loved the social interaction
and proved to be a good students,
especially excelling
at mathematics already.
He towered over the other children,
not only those in his grades,
but also those in any great
he dominated in most sports.
Invariably finding himself in the position
of goalie on the soccer field where
there's large hands and long limbs.
It was virtually impossible
to get the ball past him.
By the age of 10,
Andre stood at six feet tall and
tip the scale at around 200 pounds.
He looks,
ends move like a full
grown man on the farm.
His father discovered he could do
the work of three boys his age,
so Boris took it out of school and
put him to work full time on the farm.
There is some office had little in
the way of material possessions.
They were a close family and the children
were raised with love and dignity,
though they simply learned to accept.
Watch came without complaints.
So when Andrea was taken
from school though he missed
the mental stimulation and
the association with the school mates,
he threw himself into
the life of a farmer.
Sure.
That this was to be his lot.
The physical labor coupled with Andres
on natural growth potential allows him to
develop a level of physical
strength that stunned on look,
it's by the age of 15.
He was able to lift a car so that his
brother could change the ta without having
to worry about a wheel.
Jack.
It was around the age of 16 though that
Andres growth spurt went to a whole new
level,
is high too.
Approach seven feet and his weight
went into the three hundreds.
But his parents,
they will also really concerned about
his growth spurts and Andre was never
taken to see a doc sap
during his mid teens,
Andrea,
again,
a woodworking apprenticeship.
After two years of diligence,
application and study,
he decided that the trade was not for
him and went to work at a factory that
made hay baling entrance,
but the monotony of working on an
assembly line was worse than what it had
previously been doing.
Andre had dreams of doing
something different.
He just didn't know what that was.
With no other options.
He went back to work for his
father on the farm by now.
His incredible size was constantly
drawing attention and he became known as a
local curiosity.
By the time he was 18,
his fame had spread as far as Paris.
That was a wrestling promotion,
so he'd gone to hear about the teenage
giants who was stronger than three men.
He took the trip to car
and knocks on the door.
He told Boris and Marianne.
There's some at a future in wrestling and
the potential to make many Franks with
his parents consent.
Andrea began learning the fundamentals
of wrestling and was taken under the wing
of Montreal.
Born wrestler runs promoter,
Frank Fowler,
war.
He began on the parisiene wrestling sac.
It's under the name of Joel in
honor of a mythical French giants.
Okay.
Laundry worked as a furniture mover
during the day in order to cover his
expenses in Paris.
After work,
he could be found in a
wrestling gym slowly developing
his craft even though pro
wrestling then as now was
more entertainment than sport.
It was still necessary for
Andre to learn the basic moves,
falls,
and holds that would create the illusion
of violence while keeping him from
injury.
However,
with is intimidating,
size and strength.
It was hard to find an opponent who
was willing to share the ring with him.
As a result,
progress was slope despite this,
his sheer size and power insured,
but he never lost in the ring.
In 1965,
Andrea received a notice to
report to the army's draft board.
When he turned up for his physical exam,
the recruiters could hardly
believe what they saw.
A 19 year old who stood over seven
feet tall and weighed 350 pounds.
Despite his incredible
strength in good health,
he was deemed unfit for service for the
simple reason that the army did not have
any uniforms or shoes that were
big enough for him back in Paris,
only mess Eduardo Cop,
NCA,
a popular Montreal days,
Canadian wrestler all asking
the old man to train him.
Andre spent the next two months learning
valuable ring tips from the veteran
before leaving for home
called Pansy advised Andre
to get in the ring as much as
possible and to build experience.
He also promised that he would one day
bring Andre over to North America were
wrestling was much bigger
than it was in Europe.
Meanwhile,
Andre continued paying his
dues on the European seconds.
He traveled around Europe and even as
far as Africa developing a huge following
crowds were overwhelmed by
his sheer physical size.
Then as the match began,
they were delighted to see how
he overwhelmed his opponents.
In 1969,
Andrea ventured off the European continent
to wrestle in new where he was billed
as Monster Eiffel Tower.
Then he went to Japan where he competed
with an American partner in the Iwf
World tag team champs.
They've had one this isol and suddenly
boundary was a world champion.
It was while he was in Japan.
There's Andrea.
It was diagnosed by a doctor with the
condition that had caused his unusual
growth.
This condition was acromegaly.
It's a rare disorder of
the pituitary glands,
which leads to the overproduction
of human growth hormone.
It was caused by a benign tumor,
which if it develops before
bone growth was complete,
would lead to gigantism.
The doctor also informs Andre that life
expectancy for people with the condition
was 40 years.
Andrea told no one about his diagnosis,
keeping the secret that at 20 his life
was more than likely already half over,
but there's knowledge undoubtedly spurred
him on to reach the top of his chosen
profession as quickly
as he possibly could.
Having now won a world wrestling title,
he felt he had sufficiently paid his dues
and was ready to take on the Americans
from Japan.
He traveled to Canada where he
messed up with Eduardo carpentier.
Very became part of the
Montreal based crumb.
Pre Wrestling circuit quickly making
a name for himself on the basis of his
size,
charm,
and surprising agility in the ring.
He would often be paired against two or
even three opponents at a time in one on
one matches.
He took on undefeated such Canadian
luminaries as Calico while ski and butcher
[inaudible] on at the same time
as he was wrestling in Canada.
Andre made frequent trips back to Japan
where he was immensely popular that he
won the international wrestling
federations weld series,
defeating established stars like
Karl Gotch and Billy Robinson,
and the process Andrea hard work in
the ring was establishing him as a top
international draw cart in 1971.
He was named rookie of the
year by the wrestling yearbook.
Nineteen 72.
His biggest match today's came in May
1972 when he was pitted against the six
foot nine Mormon giants,
Don Leo,
Jonathan in what was built as the match
of the century with 20,000 people on
hands.
The match set an indoor
wrestling attendance records.
Now this match was going Andre's
way until he lost his temper.
And thrust is giant.
Hands around Leo's neck.
When his locker room guys ran into stop
him from choking out his opponents,
Andre,
toss them aside like ragdolls.
Eventually order was restored
and Andrea was disqualified.
He had lost the match,
but it also established
one of his key gimmicks.
He wants a lovable giants,
but if you make him mad,
he would turn into a killer.
After the bout with Don Leah,
Andrea began adventuring south to the
United States where he would appear as a
special attraction on the American
wrestling association carts.
Now it was time to reach out to
the biggest player in the market,
Vincent j Dot Mcmahon.
If the world wrestling federation,
Vince Mcmahon,
was first introduced to the man who
became his greatest superstar in June of
1973.
Until then,
Andre had been wrestling
under the name of Joel Fap.
Mcmahon's first move was
to rebrand the trials.
No one in America knew
who's your fair was,
but they could all relate
to Andre the giant.
Now,
as well as changing the name Mcmahon,
also modified Andres onstage approach.
Up until now,
he had shown remarkable athleticism.
Now he was to rely solely on his
overwhelming size and bulk to defeat his
opponents.
Andres first maps onto the wwf banner,
took place on March the 26th,
19,
73.
He easily defeated buddy wolf
at Madison Square Garden.
The American audience had never seen
anything like this giant of a man,
and he was immediately a
sensation mcmahon well,
he knew a good thing when he saw it.
Booking Andre to perform night
after night all over the country,
but keeping the big man moving,
Mckinnon was able to prevent the novelty
of the gentle giants from wearing off
everywhere he went.
Andrea shattered box office records.
Mcmahon was capital,
however,
not to pin him against other top drawers
for fear of damaging their prestige as
his popularity extended beyond
the wrestling community.
Andrea,
you began to receive offers for TV
appearances in the late 19 seventies.
He appeared on the tonight show.
When's the Merv Griffin show,
and was featured in such magazines
as sports illustrated and people.
In 1976,
Hollywood came calling the writer of
the most popular show on television.
The $6,000,000 man had decided to
capitalize on these string of Sasquatch
reportings that had recently been made.
They knew that there was only one man
who could realistically play the eight
foot tall forest creature,
and so it was that Andre Day covered suits
and prosthetic makeup and battles and
Lee majors has millions watched on
television to the horror of his legion of
preteen fans.
These $6,000,000 man was treated
like a ragdoll by the sasquatch.
Andrea followed up his first acting role
with a mixed discipline match fighting
boxer,
Chuck Wepner in June of 1976
at New York's share stadium.
The actually was a knockoff of Mohammed
Ali's famous matchup with Japanese
wrestler Ren Tonio and Gnocchi weapon,
or had one famous the only man to knock
down Ali and to be Sylvester Stallone's.
Inspiration for rocky.
The magic began with weapon,
a taunting Andre while seconding him
and throwing out a few jabs which the
towering restless and but he ignored.
It was well aware that he could
drop weapon at any moment,
but wanted to give the
audience their money's worth.
However,
in the third rounds weapon,
no managed to get a shot in that connects
it with Andres face and it was this
that got the big man's attention,
Andre Snort it,
and then his wepner with an inverted
atomic it drop and to headbutt.
He then picked the six foot three inch
weapon are up like a ragdoll and threw
him over the top rape.
The match with weapon had been a fast,
but it further cemented the legends
of Andre's invincibility in 1977.
He was listed as pro
wrestling illustrated.
Most popular wrestler promoters from all
over the welds pleaded for him to come
over and face off with our champion.
Okay.
Andrea had many hypes
rivalries and it's matchups.
During the period of
the late 19 seventies,
perhaps the greatest was
with Ernie big cat lat,
the six foot nine,
315 pounds.
Labs was a four time all star defensive
tackle who went on to become a career
wrestler.
He developed a very arrogant persona.
It has a pension for sticking his
thumb in the eyes of his opponents.
As a result,
he was hugely unpopular and
the perfect foil for Andrea.
The two wrestled regularly across the
country and matches build as battle of the
giants.
In 1988,
Vince Mcmahon had Andrea up with an up
and coming wrestler who had formerly been
a bodybuilder.
His name was terry.
The layer that is wwf stage name was
Hulk Hogan Mcmahon paired him up with a
theatrical easy manager by the
name of classy Freddie blassie.
Hoagie blassie were marketed as the
ultimate cheat team and the ideal
antagonists for the by the book Andre.
The tactic worked a treat with Hogan
becoming the most hated bad guy in wwf
history at 330 pounds.
So again,
marched his way through the
federation's Lesser Stars.
The fans demanded to match up with Andre
and in March of 1980 mcmahon made it
happen.
Despite his character bravado,
Hogan was terrified to
match up against Andre.
The very thought of working match with
the giants made him physically ill.
The matchup that resulted
seriously injured Hogan.
He recalls that Andre
messed up my shoulder,
screwed my neck out,
and Suplex to me on the head.
It soon became clear that Andrea
has a personal dislike for Hogan.
They traveled together to Japan for a
series of mattress as they went around the
country.
Andre continued to talk
to the young wrestler,
sitting in the back of the bus so that
he could bounce is empty beer cans off
the back of her head.
Hogan excepted the humiliating treatment
as something of a rite of passage by
the age of 34.
Andre had become the biggest
thing in the world of wrestling,
but to those outside of that world,
he was generally seen as little
more than a side show freak.
He was constantly subjected to the stairs
and jeers of the public and then there
were the discomforts imposed by his
guard down and she went frame and he
suffered from agonizing back pain and
joint elements and he could never find a
chair or a bed.
The provided anything approaching compass,
and of course always in the back of his
mind was the knowledge that his time was
running out.
He wasn't meant to make it past 40.
Andres.
Appetite for food was impressive,
but it was nothing compared to his liking.
Alcohol,
he loved French wine and would often
drink an entire case before lunch,
during more than one all
night drinking session,
he would knock back in excess of 100
handles of beer and even after this he
would show this little
sign of drunkenness.
Andrea and Hogan continued in their
[inaudible] through the end of 1980,
drawing huge crowds,
but by the next year,
Hogan had left the wwf over a disagreement
with mcmahon over his role in rocky
three as an 1981 began.
Andre was at the top of his game.
His rivalry with Hogan was soon replaced
with an ongoing feud with the Mongolian
giant killer Khan and I'm actually in
1981 con broad Andre to the canvas,
leaving vaginas unable to get up.
His ankle had snaps.
Andrea,
it was out for several weeks in the
storyline was that he was out for revenge.
Vein as again on July the 20th,
1981,
but the match ended in a
double disqualification.
Andre ones owns and dominates
through the early to mid eighties.
On April the seventh,
1986,
he prevailed in a 20 man battle royale
to come off the fixer at wrestle mania to
following Wrestlemania to Andre,
took a break from wrestling after a
decade and a half in the ring his body,
it was breaking down the health
effects of his disease where I'll say
compounding.
During this period,
he was given a pause in the
Rob Reiner directed movie,
the princess bride.
He played the role of the lovable drudge
physic and what has become a cult movie
classic rezonings to the WWF.
In 1987,
Andre faced up to his old nemesis,
Hulk Hogan,
who was also back in the wwf fault.
At wrestlemania three,
Andre weighed in at 520 pounds.
This puts a huge strain on his joints
and his lower back causing constant pain
in the final match shop.
Hogan defeated Andre with what became
known as the body slam heard around the
wells.
Hogan tourism has Dorsi muscle in the
monumental effort required to hoist the
giants over.
Had Andre though he got his revenge and
a rematch that was ed on the main events
in February of 1988.
He defeated Hogan and took the wwf
world heavyweight championship from him.
Andre went on for another four years,
but he wasn't the wrestler
that he had been in the past.
His body was racked with pain sometimes
to the point that he couldn't stand
without leaning on the ropes.
Andre owned a ranch in North Carolina
and spend more and more time.
There is this health deteriorated.
He was there and then January of 1993
when he heard that his father had died
back in France.
He helps on the next plane in
order to attend the funeral.
After the funeral,
he stayed on to spend time
with his mother and siblings.
On the night of January the 27th,
he died in his sleep as a result
of congestive heart failure.
His mother intended to bury
him alongside his father,
but Andre had recently revised as well
stating that he wished to be cremated in
accordance with his wishes.
His ashes were returned to the United
States and scattered on the grounds of his
ranch hotel,
be back in America and around the world.
Millions of fans mourns the loss
of the biggest and baddest man.
Do you ever step into the ring?
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday.
Won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the race and as always,
thank you for
chicken.